jacques chirac dans le quartier du
val-fourré à mantes-la-jolie un
plaidoyer pour l'intégration et contre
la violence dans une ville qui fut
marquée par de très grave incident le
produit sera exprime ses regrets après
le grave incident qui l'a opposée hier à
la droite à propos de l' affaire dreyfus
et de l'abolition de l'esclavagé
c'est sans doute un record du monde dans
le genre en grande bretagne une femme de
60 ans a mis au monde naturellement un
petit garçon qui se porte très bien
comment ce une secte
recrutez vous en brigade c'est notre
enquête de ce soir qu'il relate dans le
détail ces différentes étapes et l'on
s'aperçoit que chacun d'entre nous peut
être concerné championnats d'europe de
patinage une médaille de bronze pour le
couple français sarah abitbol stéphane
bernadis qui ont tenté mais manqué une
figure qui pourrait leur valoir le titre
olympique à nagano ben monsieur bonsoir
les problèmes de la violence dans les
quartiers difficiles des villes
françaises qui ne quitte guère la une de
l'actualité depuis plusieurs mois
maintenant les hommes politiques ont
bien compris qu'il leur fallait trouver
au moins un début de solution à ce
phénomène inquiétant conséquences du
chômage de la crise des valeurs morales
de la société est de la responsabilité
des parts au prix public a donc profité
de l'inauguration d'un hôpital à mantes
la jolie pour lancer aujourd'hui un
plaidoyer pour l'intégration et contre
la violence dans un quartier le
val-fourré qui s'était rendu tristement
célèbre en 1991 par une série
d'incidents bramati une visite
présidentielle
très attendu par les jeunes du quartier
véronique syntonisent mathieu chez elle
et ses quatre enfants s'était fait un
événement joue vraiment à jouer c'est la
venue du président de la république
monsieur jacques chirac
voilà c'est tout de suite c'est parti on
s'écoute à je dois citer la radio
branchée de mantes la jolie
jacques chirac est dans leur ville alors
les jeunes de cette radio bien conscient
d'être au coeur du débat politique se
sont mobilisés pour suivre le président
pas à part grâce à un envoyé spécial
et sinon que le contact du président
déchu serre la main à la main au jour et
vous avez quelques rues plus loin le
président de la république sert en effet
autant de mains qu'il peut dans le
contexte actuel d'insécurité et de
violence des banlieues
jacques chirac a voulu venir ici pour
tenter de fixer quelques repères aux
jeunes ils parlent de l'autorité
nécessaire mais aussi d'espoir et en
appelle à la mobilisation et à la
responsabilité de tous je souhaite qu'on
voit davantage tous ces jeunes qu'on les
entend qu'on les écoute car c'est
l'exemple qui emporte la conviction
il montre que rien n'est joué pour peu
que l'on ne sortent pas volontairement
du jeu suite de la visite nos reporters
de droite cité tente vainement d'obtenir
à l'entretien ou aimer par une radio qui
fait disent qu'ils travaillent avec les
jeunes comme un milord temps des
vignerons sans doute ce rendez-vous raté
jacques chirac poursuivi en inaugurant
l'hôpital flambant neuf
deux jours après son entretien à
l'elysée avec les 12 maires le chef de
l'état veut se poser en garant de la
cohésion sociale c'est aussi une façon
pour lui de ne pas laisser au seul
gouvernement
l'immense dossiers de la ville a dit les
femmes sont de retour au studio
déçus ils n'ont pas pu interviewer le
président pourtant j'ai tenté un moment
donné je me suis retrouvée face à face
devant le président de la république et
c'est là où je lui posais la question
est ce que je peux vous poser une
question pour la rdc radio droit de cité
màj presse non pas pour le moment s'il
vous plaît c'est fahim a tout de même
obtenu la promesse d'être reçus bientôt
à l'elysée avec peut-être à la clé un
portrait dédicacé pour compléter la
collection de la radio le quartier du
val-fourré à mantes-la-jolie c'est 25
mille habitants dont 50 % d'immigrés
dans la plus grande zone à urbaniser de
france qui bénéficie du statut également
de zones franches permettant aux
entreprises qui s'y installent d'être
exonérés d'impôts reportage daniel
wolfromm frédéric ii
au pied des barres du val fourré depuis
un an une quinzaine de sociétés se sont
implantés c'est une zone franche créé
entre autres ont donné du travail aux
jeunes du quartier problème
ceci ne semble pas au courant comme ça
pourtant non pas sur cinq lancers
réservé c'est un quota imposé par l'état
mais moi je peux très bien prendre
quatre seules personnes qui sont dans la
zone à partir du moment où ce sont des
gens qui ont envie de travailler il n'y
a pas de raison parce que mon nom le
tenant debout et soudés avec moi le
véhicule provincial et fédéral
tout cela vous avez fait quoi pour moi
sont de moi j'ai rapidement eu ma chance
dans la pâture à la pâture comme il est
fait à saper peintre ben justement c'est
quelque chose qui peut m'intéresser
c'est normal ce salon pour les
coordonnées qui font la loi et une vi
pubis à mon intention mais est ccs et
ses petits travaux à domicile jardinage
plomberie pose d'antennes cette société
propose depuis peu des services en tous
genres aux habitants de ce quartier
défavorisé l'échéance matin de la zone
franche permet de ne pas payer de
charges patronales jamais cette
entreprise n'aurait pu s'installer sur
cet avantage
ils sont trois employés dont un du
quartier et deux gérants associés la pub
on aura le haut niveau travail c'est
très très humain mais ne grande
convivialité entre cinq équipes que l'on
fait partager et que l'on peut partager
ensuite à nos clients ce qui fait que
c'est fait par rapport à toutes ces
grandes entreprises qui passent le
personnel le jette comme on dit là on a
plaisir à les travailler les dépanner
les clients
le chauffeur c'est le commercial de la
société il ne rechigne pas à aller sur
le terrain et confirme que l'ambiance
s'améliore au val fourré je sais que
parfois les commerçants du marché se
plaignent qu'ils ont des problèmes avec
les jeunes mais dans l'ensemble je sais
que nous à notre niveau
avec le retour de la sécurité
mantes-la-jolie attend beaucoup de sa
zone franche
elle permettrait la création de
centaines d'emplois dans ces cités
l'intégration dont a parlé le président
de la république la solidarité ce ne
sont pas que des mots ce sont aussi des
dizaines d'actions ponctuelles comme ses
élève d'une grande école l'école
supérieure d'électricité qui donne des
cours de soutien scolaire et parraine
des enfants qui risquerait sans eux de
se retrouver en situation d'échec
nathalie moisan jacques berniche premier
sourire à isma reconnu sa marraine
deux jeunes filles de milieux différents
l'une est en 4e dans un collège de
banlieue l'autre sera ingénieur dans
deux ans pour la première fois
l'aîné fait découvrir son école à la
plus jeune premier cours le moteur à
explosion
on voit ici vous pouvez regarder au fond
maxxium la [ __ ] le volet s'ouvre est
ce que tu as tout compris
quand on roule en voiture il ya une pâle
sa veuve à l'explosion des temps pour
aller à la place de s'arrêter de
repartir pour aller tout droit
yao yala et à l'explosion de des pins on
a pu en bon poulain terreau de mécanique
il faudra réviser mais l'essentiel n'est
pas là
avec la fusion ta km de pêche et sans
c'est vous qui donnez les réponses aux
questions du questionnaire c'est plus
d'instaurer un dialogue entre le par à
une filiale de vraiment la profession
médicale on est là pour les aider c'est
le mélange des deux milieux différents
et on pense que c'est un excellent moyen
pour permettre à la foire aux collégiens
de trouver une dynamique dans leur
soutien scolaire et à la foire
permettent aux étudiants des 106 vision
problème de cohésion sociale une
démarche qui assez de l'isae isma des
amis au fil des cours de soutien que
l'aîné donne chaque semaine et sa
cadette
depuis six mois
les vacances et la journée
une expérience enrichissante bientôt
exposé sur internet
un clic et la photo des collégiens et de
leurs parents et déjà transférés sur le
site web de l'école la lutte contre la
violence dans les villes c'est encore
d'une certaine façon l'obligation de
disposer d'un système de
vidéosurveillance pour toutes les
pharmacies dans les villes de plus de
25000 habitants cette décision des
pouvoirs publics est plus ou moins bien
accueillies par les pharmaciens qui
contestent pour certains son intérêt
dans la lutte contre les simples
braquages ou attaque par des toxicomanes
en manque de drogue
jean-claude allanic claude sicard vous
entrez dans une pharmacie souriez vous
êtes filmés comme les banques
la plupart des pharmacies vont être
équipés de caméras de surveillance
la mesure est obligatoire pour toutes
les officines des villes de plus de
25000 habitants
objectif enrayer la recrudescence des
agressions ont été agressés avec
revolver avec plutôt avec toutes sortes
d'armes et c'est sûr que c'est
désagréable bien en évidence la caméra
et l'écran de contrôle joue un rôle
dissuasif mais le plus important c'est
ce boîtier discret qui permet de
déclencher la larme
on appuie sur le vide en cas de problème
et celui perlier un centre qui appelle
la police ou pompiers de surveillance
l'alerté est aussitôt enregistrées sur
cet écran qui affiche l'adresse de la
pharmacie dans le même temps apparait
sur un moniteur l'image retransmise par
la caméra nous avons une image qui nous
permet de savoir si une attaque à main
armée ou arme blanche ou autre chose et
nous allons aussi les cultes donc le son
de du site qui nous permet de mesurer
dans les changes de ré d'énervement la
dangerosité de la personne évidemment
nous reste six anciennes manières
aggraver la situation
prévenu dès les premières secondes la
police peut alors intervenir le temps
d'arriver sur place
pourtant tous les pharmaciens ne sont
pas d'accord certains contestent
l'efficacité du dispositif
d'autres l'obligation de s'équiper à
leurs frais 500 à 1000 francs par mois
les réticents ont encore huit jours pour
appliquer la loi
après le 23 janvier ils seront passibles
d'une âme
hand de dix mille francs je pense les
français du mouvement des chômeurs selon
un sondage ipsos le point 70% des
personnes interrogées trouvent cette
action justifiée contre 25% qui sont
opposés 37 % approuvent l'attitude du
gouvernement face à ce mouvement
toujours 54% estiment le contraire
les chômeurs qui continue une série
d'actions ponctuelles dans plusieurs
villes de france à paris sont
quelques-uns à couper les locaux de
l'école normale supérieure rue d'ulm les
élèves protestent contre la fermeture de
l'école décidé pour raisons de sécurité
et puis à lille ce sont les locaux de la
mairie dont martine aubry et le ministre
de l'emploi et maire adjointe qui ont
été occupées pendant quelques heures
aujourd'hui pas des chômeurs en
attendant les manifestations de samedi
prévues à paris et en province dans les
préfectures les demandes dette d'urgence
de la part des chômeurs sont pris en
compte depuis 48 heures les demandeurs
sont invités à constituer un dossier car
il n'est pas question de permettre de
toucher directement une aide financière
florence bukiya patrick démunis par ont
ils sont près de 300 depuis hier qui
défilent devant l'accueil de la
préfecture de la seine-maritime
timidement il s'enquiert des démarches à
effectuer pour bénéficier de secours
d'urgence
soulagée d'apprendre qu'ils n'ont qu'un
formulaire à remplir et quelques preuves
de leurs ressources de leurs charges
mais aussi de leurs dettes à apporter
mais ils devront attendre encore dix
jours avant de savoir s'ils ont vraiment
droit à quelque chose
trois mille francs pour une personne
seule 5000 francs pour un coût plus 1250
francs par personne supplémentaire
donc c'est à partir de ces paroles que
nous allons recevoir ou non dossiers
examinés ou non mais je ne peux pas
présager combien montant exact du
parlement roger à 46 ans il touche le
rmi depuis plusieurs années et vit avec
900 francs par mois
une fois payé son loyer et l'électricité
l'aide d'urgence il en a besoin mais
sans illusion on donne un bouteille de
lait pour enlever gpal un côté quoi je
crois que le milliard il va pas les
moyens
je crois que c'est uniquement parce que
le gouvernement en ce moment il est pris
entre deux feux
bien donner du travail aux jeunes il
peux pas en donner aux autres qu'on paie
de 30 ans et quand on a plus de 30 ans
fait travailler les trop vieux trop
vieux philippe qui a 45 ans vit de
contrats emploi solidarité ou du rmi je
vis avec moins de 1400 francs en fait
parce que quand on a tous retirés en
fait il me reste très peu je sais pas il
me reste cinq cents francs environ
bon il faut pas compter je fasse une
sortie ou jay pendant la guerre quelque
part ou quoi que ce soit je suis 3 rien
fait
noah rien sauf peut-être à cette aide
d'urgence qu'ils demandent aujourd'hui
histoire comme il le dit lui même de
continuer à survivre
un autre sondage ipsos le point sur la
popularité du premier ministre et du
président pour la première fois une
baisse sensible de la cote de lire l
jospin qui perd 6 points à 51% de
satisfaits
jacques chirac lui perd 4 points 50 à
47% de satisfaits
retour sur la tempête politique
provoquée par les déclarations du
premier ministre hier à l'assemblée à
propos de l'attitude de la droite dans
une affaire qui nous ramène loin en
arrière puisqu'il s'agissait de
l'abolition de l'esclavagé de l' affaire
dreyfus lionel jospin a sans doute
estimé qu'il avait fait une erreur
puisque aujourd'hui il a exprimé ses
regrets j'ai vite imbert françoise david
son entourage n'y va pas par quatre
chemins quand on fait une boulette dit
on ce soir à matignon il faut avoir le
courage de leur coin
lionel jospin avait quand même le
sourire cet après-midi devant les
magistrats de la cour des comptes réuni
en audience solennelle loin des tumultes
et hier à l'assemblée
l'abolition de l'esclavagé l' affaire
dreyfus le premier ministre avait bel et
bien prévu d'en parler ce qu'il n'avait
pas soupçonné en revanche c'est
l'ampleur de la réaction de la droite je
crois que c'est vraiment un incident
parlementaire comme il en existe
beaucoup en démocratie
faut pas les dramatiser pour ce qui me
concerne c'est la première fois et j'ai
bien l'intention que ce soit la dernière
j'imagine que l'opposition la semaine
prochaine aux questions d'actualité me
fera ces reproches et je lui dirais
sûrement mes regrets chacun des leaders
de la droite depuis hier fait entendre
indignation mais pour philippe séguin
c'est un climat général qui accompagne
aujourd'hui le gouvernement et le
conduit à la faute
le mouvement des chômeurs n'est selon
lui qu'un début hélas le pire est à
venir
jeudi et la semaine parce que nous avons
la conviction que les effets de cette
politique quand ils seront perceptibles
iront à l'encontre même des objectifs
poursuivis et cette politique sera pire
qu inefficace comme on le pressent
aujourd'hui elle aggravera institutions
dernier coup de griffe dernière
remontrances philippe séguin reproche à
lionel jospin donne pas respecté la
constitution à propos du traité
d'amsterdam après les remous apparu dans
sa propre majorité
c'est une semaine décidément éprouvante
pour le premier ministre est aujourd'hui
sur la défensive et dans un article à
paraître demain dans le figaro le
président du rpr philippe seguin va
encore plus loin ils accusent le premier
ministre lionel jospin d'entretenir une
misérable guerre civile qui selon lui
profitent au front national on revenir à
l'histoire d'hier c'est vrai que sur le
plan strictement historique à propos de
l'abolition de l'esclavagé de l' affaire
dreyfus
le premier ministre a une lecture
partiale ou encore mieux un complète de
l'histoire de france
geneviève moll jean-jacques udac
lorsqu'en mai 81 françois mitterrand
dépose une roue sur le tombeau de victor
schoelcher au panthéon
c'est en hommage à celui qui dans le
gouvernement provisoire de 1848 a été
l'instigateur de l'abolition de
l'esclavagé dans ce gouvernement issu de
la révolution de février qui a mis fin
au règne de louis-philippe et créer la
deuxième république la gauche et la
droite était mêlé ailleurs comme
lamartine kéké modique et de modérés du
sentier en a de droite y en a de gauche
ils sont républicains il a plus qu à
modérer les américains de la veille mais
en fait
il n'y a pas de désaccord c'est pas un
sujet de dissentiment et par la suite
personne n'a jamais remis en cause la
pollution le sauvage dans l affaire
dreyfus les choses sont plus complexes
d'antisémitisme de l'époque avivée par
le scandale du canal de panama touche
aussi bien la droite cléricale que la
gauche anticapitaliste et anti
bourgeoise il y avait des
antidreyfusards des deux côtés et dans
le petit nombre de vraies fusées ares
autant de libéraux que d'hommes de
gauche ceux qui gouvernent c'est la
gauche qui est au pouvoir
en 1894 ce sont les républicains
la droite qui est monarchistes et les
dents l'opposition ans et
gouvernementaux pas du tout favorable à
la révision permet l'intérêt de la cré
dreyfus comme toutes les grandes crises
violet comme la guerre d'espagne où la
guerre d'algérie c'est qu'en fait les
positions ne sont pas fixés pour jour
est que à la faille un reclassement qui
fait que certains qui ont commencé à
gauche se retrouve à droite et vice et
versa il faut donc toujours faire très
attention avec l'histoire
elle n'est jamais manichéen chômeurs
donc affaire dreyfus abolition des
esclavages trois sujets qui n'ont rien à
voir mais qui sont l'illustration d'un
début d'année difficile pour lire et
jospin et chabot oui vous savez quelques
premiers ministres seulement connaissent
un véritable état de grâce était le cas
de nenê jospin comme edouard balladur en
son temps alors une bénéfice notamment
des comparaisons avec leurs
prédécesseurs et leurs méthodes de
gouvernement leur style est alors
largement célébrés et approuvés et après
sept mois à matignon et en quelques
jours
lionel jospin n'ont qu'a semblé pêcher
là où il semblait le mieux réussir sur
le terrain social lui qui veut être à
l'écouté des gens attentifs à leur
détresse a mal entendu la demande des
chômeurs et l'appel à la solidarité des
français sur le front de sa majorité de
premier ministre et avec beaucoup
d'habileté gestion subtil des rapports
de force m'écrivait sa fameuse majorité
plurielle et bien a dû rappeler à
l'ordre ses responsables à l'intérieur
et à l'extérieur du gouvernement enfin
face à l'opposition lionel jospin à
l'assemblée avait réussi à plusieurs
reprises à rassembler la gauche
en répondant vertement à ses adversaires
hier donc il a dérapé et l'opposition a
montré elle qu'elle se réveille à
quelques semaines des régionales alors
il ne faut rien exagérer après là je
spino magna on ne va pas passer à la
jospino déprime après une période
exceptionnelle le premier ministre se
retrouve face aux réalités aux attentes
qu'il a suscitées
il lui faut des résultats sur le chômage
il faudra gérer
le passage à l'euro et les réformes
aussi délicate que celle de la justice
avec des impatiences qui s'exprime et
les expositions qui se multiplient en
amour le gouvernement lionel jospin
revient au gouvernement comme les autres
certains me renda qu'il se banalise
la poste va réduire son nombre de
bureaux dans les campagnes au nom de la
lutte contre la désertification de
l'espace rural le gouvernement balladur
avait gelé ces fermetures 70 en 1993 le
tabou est donc levé aujourd'hui la poste
à 14000 bureau un certain nombre sera
donc regroupés ce qui ne va pas manquer
de provoquer des réactions sébastien
albert williams est peut-être ce que la
direction de la poste considère
aujourd'hui comme inférieures à
l'ancienne on rend service à des
personnes âgées on va les voir même pas
qu'ils ont pas de courrier simplement le
temps de dire bonjour au revoir savoir
s'ils sont toujours aussi l'ont pas eue
ne sont pas des problèmes non plus mais
ils ont des difficultés pour se déplacer
donc on ne met pas le courrier dans les
boîtes ont leurs portes mais ça est ce
que l'administration en tient compte ça
m'étonnera le gouvernement par la voix
du secrétaire d'état à l'industrie
christian pierret estime pourtant qu'il
faudra bel et bien fermé des bureaux en
zone rurale les campagnes ce sont 60 %
des dix sept mille bureaux et agences de
la poste mais 26% seulement de la
population française la sncf ou les
communes par les mairies pourrait
accueillir les services postaux comme
c'est déjà le cas dans certains villages
la poste se décharge sur les communes
alors qu'elles devraient avoir une
attitude beaucoup plus positive il ya
incompatibilité d'ailleurs avec les
activités de la poste
elles sont de deux ordres la poste
traditionnelle pour le courrier et les
activités financières
je ne vois pas que dans une commune un
maire puisse prendre sous sa
responsabilité une activité financière
et favoriser l'établissement financier
la poste plutôt qu'un autre
établissement financier mission de
service public activités financières
concurrence des entreprises privées
rééquilibrage en faveur des villes
l'établissement public prépare donc sa
réforme avec l'objectif de ne plus
perdre de l'argent comme en 95 plus d'un
milliard de francs et en 96 plus de 600
millions
la situation difficile en asie du
sud-est sera plus longue et plus
difficile que prévu dit ce soir
dominique
strauss kahn la crise financière en asie
du sud est n'est donc plus une
abstraction pour la france la société
alstom confiant que la corée du sud lui
a demandé de différer la livraison des
premières rames de tgv est qui doivent
équiper normalement les chemins de fer
coréen hold up à la voiture c'est une
véritable épidémie en belgique depuis
quelques mois les gangs ont enlevé au
moins une centaine de voitures
essentiellement de belles limousines de
diplomates en poste à bruxelles
et il n'en manque pas ces enlèvements
sont en général rondement menée grâce à
une technique bien particulière alban
nicosie vincent maillard reportage
îliens ces jours ci à bruxelles beaucoup
de très belles voitures comme cette
jaguar cabriolet oui mais seulement en
démonstration au salon de l'auto parce
que dans les rues le soir venu c'est
plutôt profil bas
une centaine de voitures de luxe ont
disparu depuis trois mois est toujours
le même scénario
sous la menace d'une arme le véritable
bande organisée aux méthodes mafieuses
pour une activité qui portent même un an
le car jacking littéralement le
détournement de voiture parmi les cibles
principales les diplomates comme il est
toujours le représentant palestinien de
la voiture lorsque j'ai voulu discuter
avec eux le mans a lâché de mon siège
j'étais d'ailleurs la direction de la
voiture j'étais seule ment jeté par
terre et un autre de ces malfrats a pris
la direction ils sont partis avec la
voiture
la représentation palestinienne qui
n'est déjà pas très riches s'est fait
prêter une nouvelle voiture mais
désormais prendre davantage de
précautions les ambassadeurs turcs
colombien chypriote allemand tous
auraient raconté la même histoire sur
100 voitures volées 15 seulement ou ont
été retrouvés sur le port du havre prêts
à embarquer pour le liban du coup les
constructeurs présentent des véhicules
adaptés concept bmw dont les vitres sont
recouvertes d'une pellicule à l'épreuve
des balles
coût estimé six cent mille francs de
quoi donner le temps à l'antenne de
progresser
les autorités belges particulièrement
sensible à l'image de bruxelles capitale
de l'europe commencent à trouver que
cette histoire de vol de limousines fait
désordre
voilà pourquoi les enquêteurs sont priés
de trouver rapidement désormais qui se
cache derrière ce trafic
les autorités françaises sont de plus en
plus inquiètes de la prolifération des
sectes sujet que l'on évoque
régulièrement à l'occasion
malheureusement de tragédie le plus
souvent plutôt que d'évoquer le problème
d'une manière générale nous allons
tenter de montrer dans l' enquête de ce
soir comment finalement on peut se
retrouver assez facilement embrigader
sent toujours s'en rendre compte
au début du moins dans ce reportage il
est question de l'église internationale
du christ fondée aux états unis une
église catalogué par les parlementaires
français comme une véritable secte
enquête
il en faudra elisabeth des souza hervé
brusini le spectacle n'a rien d'un
concert la salle gaveau a été loué pour
autre chose ce jour là
tous vont partie de l'église
internationale du christ une secte a
tendance à focaliser selon les termes
d'un rapport parlementaire
autrement dit pour échapper à la fin
toute proche du monde on peut gagner son
salut en faisant de la bible une
doctrine quotidienne et absolue de dieu
ont maintenant partie des sentiments que
j'ai eu il y aura de l'opposition
l'opposition
le ton est donné
adhérer c'est se mettre à l'écart en
opposition avec le reste de la société
une société où l'on recrute pourtant
comme ça simplement au coin de la rue
vous inviter à une réunion à chrétienne
prochainement ou même ce matin est ce
que ça m'intéressait
avec votre guide
le parcours initiatique commence
toujours dans un lieu public
sous l'oeil de notre caméra discrète
aussi la première étape de
l'enseignement on vous fait découvrir le
message de cette nouvelle église
né à boston aux états unis le
christianisme quelques longs somme de
quelque chose d'intelligent qui toujours
est acquise au prix qui montent pas un
engagement un super league
au moment où les ricains ce que tu dis
en vente sa part tellement c'est jésus
qui est ma bible qui fait qu'avant de
faire quelque chose
la décision je prends
c'est pas demander qu'est ce que
jean-louis fermé vivre à ma place
sophie courbet a longuement étudié cette
église pour elle la référence constante
à jésus c'est le début d'un rapport de
soumission à celui qui initie le
formateur n'importe quel acte ou
décision dans sa vie quotidienne il doit
demander l'avis de son formateur puisque
pour les bostoniens se soumettre à son
formateur c'est se soumettre à dieu
puisque dieu s'exprime à travers les
jeunes et en l'occurrence les formateurs
le formateur nous avions rendez vous
avec lui la rencontre se déroule dans
son appartement villa
le cérémonial il est parfaitement réglé
un abord sympathique où l'on prend note
de toutes vos réactions
l'objectif c'est de recruter c'est
l'union entre merci beaucoup c'est l'une
des tâches assignées aux formateurs
souvent des parents d'adeptes appels au
secours ce bénévole de la lutte
antisecte selon lui dans l'église chacun
surveille l'autre chaque formateur
procède à son tour un autre formateur et
le formateur a le droit d'intervenir en
disant ceci tu ne l'as pas bien fait
combien as-tu évangéliser de personnes
aujourd'hui combien combien tu donner à
la collecte
autrement dit il a le droit d'intervenir
sur tous les domaines de la vie de
l'adepte et donc c'est une prison
quelques pas cette prison eric en est
sorti il ya huit mois
meurtri son formateur lui laisse un
souvenir de père fouettard mais non
qu'ils ce mois comme c'était mon père
donc ainsi chez des choses sont pas
justes
c'est lui qui va tirer nous corriger
vais pas me taper dessus mais il va me
corriger en faisant corps avec des
passages de la bible en me disant si tu
fais bassin c'est ce qui va t'arriver
donc c'est intéressant parce que ça
qu'il travaille est intellectuellement
bien être à la tête
donc si les messieurs c'est fin de
parcours c'est jour de baptême à salle
gaveau
dieu était satisfait amplement
oui tu crois
après quatorze jours d'étude on est
officiellement chrétiens du royaume de
dieu
une nouvelle vie commence d'adeptes et
fortement encouragés à quitter sa
famille
d'autres réunions vont suivre si l'on
parle argent c'est la donne la collecte
hebdomadaire qui est basée sur le
salaire serait revenu qu on a bon gère
pour une personne comme moi qu'elle
insère c'était bon minimum 10%
célia pour moi se faisait environ 270
francs a par semaine chaque membre
reçoit ce formulaire
il faut entretenir son coeur mais
surtout donné avec fois à coups de
citations bibliques
on y indique comment gérer au mieux son
patrimoine le questionnaire est très
précis est on prêt à vendre ou à
sacrifier pour la collecte
je suis prêt à vendre tous mes biens
personnels a répondu ce membre de
l'église pour 1997 les arrondissements
du nord de la capitale ont récolté plus
de 2 millions de francs de la part des
adeptes
tous sont des victimes ce qu'ils font
ils sont persuadés le faire pour le bien
par ce qui est en jeu selon l'église du
christ c'est le salut or lorsqu'on est
convaincu que la vie éternelle est
importante et qu'elle existe en tout cas
il vaut mieux avoir le salut qu'être
d'année et donc au nom de se saluer
hypothétique
on leur fait faire absolument n'importe
quoi
tout se marie au sein même de l'église
les principaux centres sont à paris lyon
et marseille en france pour l'heure
cette église compte 1500 membres
l'actualité internationale après une
série de valse-hésitation d'ordre
protocolaire l'union européenne va
envoyer une délégation de trois
ministres des affaires étrangères en
algérie comme le souhaitait le
gouvernement d'alger qui ne voulait pas
recevoir de simples aux fonctionnaires
déjà l'ambassadeur de grande-bretagne à
lg a été autorisé à se rendre sur les
lieux du dernier drame à sidi ahmed
c'est à 25 km de la capitale une visite
qu'il a pu rendre aujourd'hui au côté
des autorités algériennes
le président clinton n'échappera pas
finalement une confrontation avec paula
jones est jeune femme qui l'accuse
d'avoir tenté de l'obliger à une
relation sexuelle à l'époque où bill
clinton n'était encore que le gouverneur
de l'arkansas et charbit les deux
visages de paula jones
d'abord celui de la jeune employée de
l'arkansas celle qui en 1994 accusait le
président de la première puissance
mondiale bill clinton de harcèlement
sexuel
et puis là même paul à quatre ans plus
tard la coiffure est plus sage mais le
regard plus déterminé que jamais à un
mauvais film pour le président et pour
les éditeurs new yorkais un roman à
succès christophe lagarde et son côté
vulgaire mais bien moins que lorsqu'elle
avait sa crinière frisée et son
maquillage un peu lourd
elle essaie d'avoir un look acceptable
pour l'amérique traditionnel mais c'est
difficile pour elle
aulas a décidé d'aller jusqu'au un
accord à l'amiable
entendez 10 millions de francs pour
aulas ayant été refusée par les avocats
du président
le procès est inéluctable ça va être un
spectacle incroyable les gens vont tout
faire pour le voir comme ces gens qui
croisent un accident au bord de la route
ils ne veulent pas le voir mais ils ne
peuvent pas s'empêcher de le regarder
lou contre look le président multiplie
devant les caméras les tendres et fusion
en compagnie de son épouse hillary
clinton
mais malgré son statut de président
malgré ce parterre de jeunes filles
venues le soutenir
il devra tout de même samedi s'expliquer
devant la justice américaine
c'est une sorte de record du monde une
femme de 60 ans habitant le pays de
galles vient de donner naissance un peu
garçons qui se porte bien au terme d'une
grossesse naturelle londres etienne
leenhardt l'état civil de cardiff et les
autorités de l'hôpital de clamart donne
sont formels l'agricultrice qui lie à
deux mois a donné naissance ici sans
aucun recours à la fécondation assistée
à un petit garçon prénommé joseph est
bien né le 10 février 1937 elle a donc
presque 61 ans elisabeth peteul veut
rester anonyme mais tous les journaux
applaudissent et les médecins cherchent
à te la comprend il faut savoir qu'avant
la légalisation de l'avortement et avant
que les techniques de stérilisation ne
se développent les femmes avaient plus
fréquemment des enfants à 40 ou 50 ans
que maintenant
jusqu'ici les spécialistes évalué à 57
ans l'âge jusqu'auquel il était possible
à l'extrême de repousser les limites de
la ménopause l'extraordinaire naissance
de joseph est selon eux aussi explicable
par la génétique la mère de madame
buttle étant elle même tombée enceinte
très tardivement la précédente
détentrice du record kathleen gamble
devenu l maman à 55 ans s'est déclaré
ravi cette naissance vient en tout cas
partiellement occulté le scandale
provoqué il ya trois ans par cette
italienne devenue maman à 63 ans à la
suite d'une fécondation in vitro
madame buttle nous dit-on en tout cas ne
comprends pas que l'on fasse tout un
plat de cette affaire et s'est dit
enchanté d'avoir donné un petit frère à
son fils aîné qui est âgé lui de 35 ans
le sport maintenant avec le championnat
d'europe de patinage artistique c'était
aujourd'hui le jour de la danse hier
soir le couple français abitbol bernadis
a décroché la médaille de bronze est
raté le titre pour une figure manqué qui
aurait sans doute permis d'obtenir la
médaille d'or si elle avait été réussi
yann lavoix il voulait devenir champion
d'europe
alors ils ont tenté une première en
patinage un triple axel lancer leur
audace a été mal récompensés sarah
abitbol et stéphane bernadis sont une
fois de plus monté sur la troisième
marche d'un podium européen
ils ont pris le pari de réussir ce
triple axel ou jeux olympiques
d'autant que l'on a vu cet après midi en
danse lors du programme original que
tout était possible
brych la coiffe les imbattables et
perfectionniste ont trébuché
ils sont deuxièmes avant le programme
libre de demain et juste derrière eux on
trouve la jeune garde française
m
troisième avant le programme libre
marina anissina et gwendal peizerat
semble très bien préparés et leur
objectif dépasse le strict cadre de ces
championnats d'europe
ça fait déjà dans quatre compétitions
qu'on fait depuis le début de la saison
donc là on commence à vraiment bien
sentir dedans c'est vraiment des
programmes qui sont rodés alors bien sûr
il ya toujours un plus à apporter
d'essayer jeux olympiques on va
travailler encore plus sur l'émotion
m
après les du chesnay après moniotte et
lavanchy relégué à la 7e place
aujourd'hui
voici la relève du patinage français et
contrairement aux apparences ils ont
déjà tous les deux la tête tournée vers
nagano une nouvelle course à la voile
partira samedi de new york destination
san francisco le tour du continent
américain comme à l'époque d'avant le
percement du canal de panama
parmi les concurrents le vainqueur du
dernier vendée globe challenge
christophe auguin reportage les soldes
duchiron frédéric bazille la statue de
la liberté et christophe auguin s'est
pas encore l'amérique c'est à paris oh
bien sûr scène décembre 97 la fin de
l'année l'année du vendée u tour du
monde en solitaire qui l'a consacré
auprès du public et les médias
un genre d'années qui vous paye 10 pas
ordinaire on peut certes on pète c'est
pas quelque chose que je cherche je suis
pas toujours faux bond au chant et et je
souhaite pas donc j'aime bien ma petite
vie tranquille au foot et en 1997
l'agenda de christophe auguin était
plein de rendez 17 février rendez vous
avec la gloire la victoire dans le
vendée globe aux sables d'olonne 6 avril
rendez vous avec l'émotion à granville
des larmes pour le retour triomphal à la
maison 20 juin rendez vous avec le
président de la république qui lui remet
la croix de chevalier de la légion
d'honneur passent les jours et les
semaines christophe auguin et la statue
de la liberté
cette fois c'est new york c'est une
nouvelle année un nouveau parcours une
nouvelle épreuve au christophe auguin
new york san francisco
c'est aussi un nouveau monde fini le
monde du silence en solitaire avec ou
sans escale trois courses autour du
globe et trois victoires comme qu'on
peut faire le tour du monde et le tour
de la question
cette fois aucun repart avec quatre
équipiers et copains d'abord je bonnes
gens étaient complètement le solide
perdre peut être quelqu'un quelques
petites courses mais
j'aurais nous consacrer plus à
l'équipage où les français méritent une
place bien meilleure au niveau mondial
peut fait qu'ils ont actuellement samedi
prochain christophe auguin et son
équipage s'élanceront de manhattan en
passant devant la statue de la liberté
ils pourront lui rendre hommage n'était
elle pas d'une certaine manière la mère
de tous les marins et le poète n'at-il
pas écrit un jour homme libre toujours
tu chériras la mer vient des films à
sortir cette semaine sur les écrans en
france une confrontation au plus haut
niveau entre al pacino et keanu reeves
dans l'associé du diable qui raconte le
combat entre le diable al pacino est un
jeune avocat
le tout sur fond de new york pascal
deschamps est en train de mourir ils
pensent rencontre au sommet sur les
toits de métal à ma gauche jeunes loups
du vin rouge venus de province à mayotte
le diable sous les traits d'un des plus
puissants avocat au monde dans la
balance fortune et gloire le marché
habituel la pression ça peut tout
changer la pression sous la pression ça
fait une personne s'épanouissent autres
ces fonds rencontre au sommet de la
fiche à ma gauche une jeune star au
parcours original à ma droite un
briscard aguerri qui a pourtant hésité
avant de revêtir l'habit sulfureux et
quand vous avez dit oui c'est votre
vanité qui a parlé
mais qui dit famille et que des traces
koubbi
car il ya un message derrière tout ça le
jeune avocat tombera dans le panneau
sacrifiera famille amour pour
s'apercevoir mais trop tard qu'il a été
l'instrument des desseins criminels du
malin l'occasion de fustiger les
arrivistes de tout poil qui font passer
leur soif de succès avant tout vaste
propos c'est facile pour toi tu es
nouveau costume du tout va bien c'est
pas aussi simple que tu le crois mari je
sais qu'on est couvert de fric et si tu
possèdes il ne savait pas à force
d'hésiter entre le fantastique la fable
métaphysique et la critique sociologique
le film peine à trouver son identité
à vouloir trop pour faire on veut au
cinéma aussi péché par orgueil
regardez bien cette image une image en
forme de tableaux de l'école hollandaise
un vol d'étourneaux plusieurs millions
entre les moulins de la région de kinder
gic
c'est en hollande
rappel des principaux titres de
l'actualité de ce jeudi d'abord le
président de république jacques chirac
dans le quartier du val-fourré à
mantes-la-jolie vont un plaidoyer pour
l'intégration et contre la violence dans
une ville qui fut marquée par deux grâce
je suis ensuite et en 1980 le premier
ministre qui exprime ses regrets après
le grave incident qui l'a opposée hier à
la droite à propos de l' affaire dreyfus
et de l'abolition de l'esclavagé dans un
instant la météo sophie davant point
route valérie maurice vincent 50 envoyé
spécial spécial cambodge ce soir dans le
magazine de paul nahon et bernard
benyamin demain 4 vérités c'est un 5 ans
françoise laborde recevra hubert védrine
ministre des affaires étrangères de la
france
et puis demain soir ici même vous
retrouverez béatrice schönberg pour plus
week-end voilà je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée sur notre chaîne
bonsoir